at this point they enjoy it Nick Cannon
revealing how his kids with Mariah Carey
feel about having so many siblings tend
to be exact
kids you know I got a lot of them that's
what life is about that's why we're on
the planet Nick opens up on the Howie
Mandel does stuff podcast I have never
been a person that shy away from talking
about my life and a big part of Nick's
life the 12 children he shares with
multiple women hopefully people get to
know me in a very intimate way to where
if um in the headlines the night before
I'm definitely talking about it the next
morning so what do his firstborn kids 11
year old twins Moroccan and Monroe think
of their growing fam at this point they
enjoy it you know and they have fun and
they're the oldest and but who knows
where that will go uh in you know once
16 hits the twins turned 12 on April
30th and Nick explains how their
relationship is evolving as they get
older this is my first time ever having
12 year olds and I got you know a set of
them to where
there now we're having real
conversations and and you know their
their life is far from normal because
you know the mom's one of the biggest
you know entertainers to ever live and
right uh and their dad is me and then so
it's like so they but we they're so
intelligent they're so in tune they're
so in line with their own values but we
have challenging conversations sometimes
yeah that includes combos about their
siblings and some of the controversies
that have surrounded Nick over the past
decade the thing that they do know is
like hey dad up dad makes mistakes
aside from the twins he shares with
Mariah Nick also has five-month-old rise
two-year-old powerful and six-year-old
golden with Brittany Bell
three-month-old beautiful and
one-year-old twins Zion and zillion with
Abby De la Rosa two-month-old Halo and
late son Zen with Alyssa Scott
seven-month-old legendary with Bree tacy
and five-month-old Onyx with Lynn Nisha
Cole they get my full attention when I'm
not not working and that's that's the
beauty of it because like it kind of
keeps me out of trouble it's like either
work or playing with my kids so does
Nick plan to have more he says he's not
ruling it out which Echoes what he told
E.T in 2021. I did hear that you said
Lord willing you would like to have more
kids I come from a big family I just
have such a love and passion for kids
and families so I was always like yo I
want a big family too so you know the
Lord has blessed me with what I asked
but you're asking you shall receive I'm
not sitting out here planning it you
know what I mean like my therapist says
I should be celibate
[Laughter]
but for now Nick says I'm good with my
doesn't
[Music]